is laryss the new varus is harwin a real
contender for vanira's hand as house of
the dragon speeds ahead here are a few
things you may have missed in episode
three
as damien cordless and their forces are
dealing with the crab feeder the landed
gentry of king's landing discussed the
matter first over a pre-journey pig rose
to the castle then in the kingswood
before the hunt as camp is assembling
the ladies of some of the seven kingdoms
great houses are gathered in the main
tent and when rhaenyra joins them
mid-conversation they're gossiping about
someone named lady johanna swann who was
abducted from one of the ships sailing
through the stepstones what will happen
to lady john
she's to be sold to a pillow house in
the free cities if you believe the
rumors
[Music]
to those unfamiliar with the book house
of the dragon is based on this might
seem like filler dialogue however lady
joanna swann is specifically mentioned
in fire and blood in the text the people
of the seven kingdoms become
increasingly perturbed by the triarchy's
occupation of the stepstones because the
crab feeder isn't just stealing their
goods and coins he's human trafficking
their women and children into the
pleasure houses in lady johanna's case
her cheap uncle the lord of stonehelm
refused to pay their tolls so they took
his niece instead martin writes johanna
rose to become the celebrated quarterson
known as the black swan and the ruler of
least in albert name
fire and blood doesn't elaborate on that
rice as it doesn't tie back into the
central targaryen heavy narrative
besides the targaryens valarians and
hightowers palace intrigue in house of
the dragon involves some other
high-ranking families with which game of
thrones fans will already be familiar
the lannisters and the strongs sir
thailand lannister is serving as master
of ships in corliss's absence while his
twin sir jason lannister occupies
casterly rock and once rainier is hand
in marriage lord lionel strong is
currently the ruler of harrenhal as well
as the king's master of laws his two
sons harwan and laris make brief
appearances in episode three more on
harwin in a moment but dolores is a
young man who joins the ladies after
he's self-deprecating the equips that
the gods have not made him for hunting
the camera focuses on the odd booty
wears around his malformed foot in fire
and blood hilarius is sometimes referred
to as clubfoot he walks with a limp and
is regarded as a quiet man whose
intentions are difficult to decipher
leris doesn't sit with the ladies only
to excuse himself from strenuous
activity he's a various like character
with a knack for disappearing into the
background and picking up on valuable
information
episode 3 asks a pair of deeply related
questions will king viserys decide to
name aegon ii is heir instead of
rhaenyra and who will the princess marry
based on his comments to his daughter in
the carriage and on the look on his face
as sir jason lannister looks at his
daughter viserys seems to have made an
informal agreement prior to the hunt but
besides the fact that jason is doing a
terrible job of worrying the princess
and smoothing the king he's got
competition but ceres complains that
he's drowning in marriage offers thus
far the show has given rhaenyra six
possible suitors besides jason who blows
his chances with his treasonous
assumptions otto hightower suggests
two-year-old aegon ii
which even the king thinks is gross
meanwhile lionel strong argues that lane
or velaryon is the wisest choice but
it's obvious that rhaenyra prefers the
company of sir kristen cole she's
creating opportunities to be alone with
him and the princess and her swan
protector openly flirt with each other
in a very game of thrones kind of way
you want me to kill
him audiences may have also picked up on
some romantic tension between rhaenyra
and her uncle damon and the ladies at
court are aware of their mutual
affection too but there's one more
player in the game for rhaenyra's heart
when lionel strong asks if the king
wishes to hear his opinion viserys
guesses he's about to propose his eldest
son harwin the strongest knight in the
seven kingdoms harwin is the man who
caught the brown stag and the man with
whom rhaenyra exchanges a glance as he
processes its meat
sir otto hightower succeeds in elevating
his daughter to the position of queen
but now he's determined to elevate his
grandson to the iron throne though he's
close enough to viserys to know the king
as an alter the succession the hand is
working every angle to get what he wants
he's scheming with the lords of powerful
houses he's pressing queen allison ii in
his words leader husband to reason he
tries to make a match between rhaenyra
and aegon ii as a fail-safe and with his
counsel he attempts to influence the
series without overstepping boundaries
when a white stag is spotted in the
kingswood otto sets the man after it and
tells vaseris that the sighting is a
regal portent throughout the episode he
and those loyal to him and queen allison
pushed the idea that should they catch
and kill the king of the forest it's
surely a sign that the gods favor aegon
ii
before the dragons roared over westeros
white heart was the symbol of royalty in
these lands tellingly the shrewd otto
hightower never explicitly claims that
the stag's appearance means the gods
want little aegon to rule instead of
rhaenyra he only implies as much through
flattery and superstition both of which
are vulnerabilities of the king but the
animal they are tracking turns out to be
a brown stag which viserys struggles to
put out of its misery so otto's plan
backfires meanwhile rhaenyra and kristin
happen upon the white stack whom she
chooses to let live without hesitation
the war for the stepstones takes place
over a few pages in fire and blood and
it's begun and resolved in one episode
of house of the dragon but like the book
its effects are sure to ripple
throughout the rest of the story though
precisely how might be a significant
departure in print king viserys actually
approves of damon's private war because
it's keeping him busy and away from the
real business of governing at king's
landing according to martin damon and
callers had little difficulty assembling
an army and won many victories during
the first two years of the conflict with
daemon's dragon and corliss's vast fleet
of ships damon easily dispatches the
crab feeder when they meet by
decapitating him with his sword dark's
sister in the show damon and cordless
have their backs against the wall the
rogue prince is angry when a messenger
arrives with news that the king is
sending back up though they need the
help he doesn't want it as this was
supposed to be his show of strength to
contrast his reputation with that of his
weak brother in another change from the
book lenore is also present as is his
dragon sea smoke but one of the most
noticeable differences is the appearance
of the crab feeder who isn't described
outside of his penchant for sex slavery
and crustacean-induced torture house of
the dragon has given him a severe case
of greyscale which he hides behind a
broken mask of the sons of the harpy a
group that opposed daenerys's role in
game of thrones so not only has damon
been bailed out he's also potentially
been exposed to this disfiguring and
often fatal illness
[Music]